[Musique]
partisane et qu'on avait bla bla bla bla
c'est tout donnez moi ma chance la
désillusion des électeurs ne décourage
pas le candidat bloquiste simon marchand
je vais tout faire pour que ça se fasse
c'est la troisième fois qu'il se
présente dans la circonscription
d'hochelaga en 2019 il a perdu par
environ 300 voix contre la candidate
libérale dès le lendemain quand on parle
aux gens dans la rue dit ouais c'était
tellement sûr que sa lettre le bloc je
suis juste pas aller voter donc cette
année quand on parle aux gens qui disent
cette année je le sais que c'est
important j.sery je comprends que chaque
vote compte dans l'urne il peut compter
sur celui d'henri tremblay j'ai toujours
pour valve voter bloc et puis à toute
franchise cyber et on parle de cette
année des loges bien gérée pauvres des
blocs c'est-à-dire à cause justement du
jeu à 72 ans ça fait maintenant sept ans
qu'il attend un logement abordable
il ya des agenais qui sont fermées
jusqu'à 3 juin y a personne que j'habite
son port et n'avait jusque là à faire
gouvernement j'ai des reines avec des
distribuer aux gens et déjà 14
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est aussi le sujet des habitués de la
rue ontario avec leurs emblématiques
triporteur et leurs maris gotham
enchères ça prend des achats l'ère des
copépodes
de condos dit il depuis quelques années
l'embourgeoisement à créer de nouveaux
défis pour les organismes communautaires
comme beaucoup de jeunes familles de
jeunes professionnels m'ont aussi des
jeunes familles en difficulté on le voit
par exemple dans les écoles où on a
perdu certaines mesures aliments part
parce que les indices de défavorisation
se transformer à cause de chemin la
création par exemple d'une tour à condos
dans un secteur défavorisé l'anxiété du
logement là je la comprends la députée
libérale sortante défend son bilan on a
livré une allocation au logement qui
n'existaient pas ici l'art schlager on a
rénové deux hlm qui était écoute en
décrypte depuis plus de 30 ans
sincèrement j'ai plus fait en 18 mois
que l'ancien député en huit ans pas
assez pour philippe gros hic québécois
anglophones son vote ira à
l'environnement c'est un problème puis
je me suis ici qui veut qu'à
la
totalité de ville
déçu des libéraux il songe à voter pour
le npd aussi l'impression sur les
changements climatiques
la candidate néo-démocrate fait beaucoup
campagne sur ce point dans schnyder au
niveau environnement mais on a un enjeu
très concrets qui est l'annoncé de
raymond la justice et
raymond logistique c'est un projet de
plateforme de transbordement pour
accueillir environ 10000 conteneurs sur
ce terrain contaminé c'est devenu le
projet de la discorde contre lequel les
citoyens qui sont mobilisés ce projet
lors implique du bruit un îlot de
chaleur immense on parle d'à peu près
quarante six terrains de football
l'asphalté
pour plusieurs d'entre eux s'ils ont une
numéro un il le choix est difficile
puisque les trois candidats se sont
positionnés contre le projet faut que
les bottines suivent les babines
donc on verra je ne sais pas qui est
vraiment le pouvoir d'agir parce que
c'est quand même il ya des enjeux qui
sont très fédéraux aussi le on se le
cachera pas avec le port et tout le cn
mon choix un peu fermé
mais en même temps on veut pas
d'utiliser les bottes ont fait cesser
ces politiques flamandes ainsi pas
facile
avec un électorat volatil qui a changé
d'allégeance trois fois en dix ans la
course ici se jouera à trois jusqu'à la
fin issigeac audry charbonneau radio
canada dans la circonscription
d'hochelaga